Before we say goodbye, we'd like to play a quick round of
Drewth or dare.
(crowd cheers)
(applause)
And we have an audience member, where is Priya (indistinct)?
Priya, hi.
Hi.
Hi, Priya.
Okay, so anything goes here,
but is it gonna be a Drewth or is it gonna be a dare?
I challenge you to a dare.
All right!
Bring it on, Priya.
I dare you to a staring contest with me.
You know the rules, first one to blink loses.
(Ross laughs)
All right, let me get all my blinks out.
And go.
(suspenseful music)
Oh, this is riveting.
How will blink first?
(Ross and Drew scream)
It stings!
Yeah!
Let's go!
I love that, "Yeah, yeah!"
Well done.
Thank you, Priya.
Thank you for choosing to spend your time with us everybody.
Oh, thank you so much for coming here.
We make this show for you, so
Take it with you!
(upbeat music)